all right randy and steven welcome back
hello hello how you doing
so
how did you guys meet
we'll continue on from where we talked
last time um
we actually met on the internet
many years before one of those postings
like a grinder or whatever no no i
actually know he's one of the guys i did
thank you
facebook yeah yeah
i was dating my ex and yeah and i just
moved back here um from virginia and i
kind of moved back in at um kind of like
a tough situation i went back in with my
mom and to the house um that she used to
own
and there was no uh electricity no water
no um
pretty much and i kind of i needed
somebody to be there for me and i
everybody that i met and talked to he
was the only one that kind of came at me
correct you know came at me without uh
being like on a you know in a sexual way
or in a way to make me uncomfortable is
there so there's a gay community here in
in uh charleston um yeah not too big not
really big but yeah there's a gay
community but they were on the dl
mm-hmm 90 percent of western dean's gay
anyway so
now i'm just kidding
um only when the door closes again it's
interesting yeah i mean so you guys have
all these
little
you know so you're you're interracial
you're gay
one of you has a disability
[Music]
poverty is a big part of your life right
right
yeah yeah
what else drug addiction mm-hmm
and the story goes on
you check all the boxes yeah yeah yeah
i mean with all these
with all these obstacles that make your
lives difficult i mean how
what what keeps you
pushing on
um god
and hope and faith one day things will
you know
will get better and
not to let my dad down my mom was
my dad passed away last year from lung
cancer so i'm just like that hope for a
better life you know what i mean you
still have hopes yes always religion
helps you guys
um
i believe in god and jesus or something
did you guys feel like your families let
you down
yes
especially right at this time when
you know my family has to get bury to
help us and they don't um
you know like
my brother have a brother and sister i
called my sister the other night needed
some help didn't even answer my family
definitely i don't exist to my family so
basically i don't really feel like it i
never really had a lot of family anyway
so i don't really expect too much
anyways so you guys have each other
that's it exactly that's that's what it
is we're each other's family that's what
we tell each other all the time isn't it
seriously we got
we're on
we only got each other mm-hmm
i mean we
we passed a bridge where you depend on
people but you can't always depend on
people because people in life will let
you down
my grandmother told me don't put your
eggs all in one basket because if you
stumble and fall and you break all of
them you have nothing and cook for
breakfast later on which is weird though
because you say that but here we are
when we get out of there seven years it
don't even seem like that long kind of
just flew by and that seemed like he you
know he's all i really know
i wouldn't know you know i wouldn't know
what life would be without him really
i think he's calling me an old man i was
like
you're 30 years old today no i'm 29 30
yeah today's randy's birthday right he
doesn't know how to count i said do you
know how to count
happy birthday thank you
so how far did you guys go in school
oh i went to um 11th grade and dropped
out and then i went back to job corps
and i got my ged and i got a dental
assisting trade
and that's it so far
i graduated high school only one of my
whole family did went off to college got
business management
and political science so i went on got
some college and stuff so
what kind of work have you guys done in
your lives
i was a manager at walmart to see what
they call csm
i worked at dog track and gambling
facility in west virginia
i smoked a gun crowd
just all jumped all over the place so
drugs played a part in that because
in west virginia a lot of people can't
go to work without being high
i've done all kinds of different work
i've done everything from retail
to
customer service um fast food
a little bit of everything honestly i've
been working since i was 16 so i have
all kinds of job experience
have you guys traveled you've been
around the country um
a little bit yeah i was kind of gypsy
when i was a little kid my mom's got a
gypsy kind of moved us all over the
place
i just tried moved around all the places
in west virginia like have you ever left
west virginia oh yeah
you've never been outside of west
virginia nope that's crazy ain't it wow
that's what i said it's a small state
too
we're gonna do some traveling
this is definitely something we gotta do
i'm gonna go to walt disney world i
always wanted to
living in this part of the country you
know it's already tough enough without
all your other
obstacles
it just makes a person tough doesn't it
yes it does oh yeah you have tough thing
you have to have tough skin if you have
thin skin you're gay and you know
minimally interrelated relationship
you're not going to make it you don't
get your feelings hurt yeah those toughs
that thin skins will come off fast
so
and you're like that we're like that i
don't even really recognize it and leave
my doctor said she's like you always
walk around act like you're so tough and
dead i'm really looking myself i gotta
think about it like that yeah i guess it
kind of just exudes like it just kind of
naturally comes off me like that you've
always been this
in this situation so my whole life i
guess i'm kind of adapted to i'm used to
it honestly
did the fact that uh
i mean you guys talked about this last
time a little bit that
stephen you have hiv and you think maybe
you got it from randy
i'm pretty sure
no no you know you don't know for sure
when it comes to that but yeah
did that put a strain on your
relationship
i forced it
at first it was kind of hard
for me to accept it but when he told me
he was hiv positive
he like thought i was gonna hit him and
stuff and i was like
i was like i'm not gonna get what's done
is done you know
what person would i be so you're having
unprotected sex without knowing that oh
yes right yeah
i think he kind of already knew anyways
i really didn't know
he claims i knew but i really did not
know
would have changed um
probably the first night
but through the night though probably
not it wouldn't have made a difference
but of course you probably would have
but throughout the night it probably
wouldn't know
and that makes sense yeah that's a
terrible thing to say but it is what it
is
honestly i waited i waited probably i
want to say i waited at least three four
days before i actually told him
now he waited three months to tell me
right yeah
he's i told you he couldn't count
told you there's still a little
resentment
no no it's just not nobody said man is
he can't accept he wouldn't say three
days he's telling me
well if it's three days or three months
it doesn't make it right it doesn't make
it wrong and regardless i mean three
months
but i didn't test positive tell which
was strange was a year after i met him i
didn't test parts of him telling us yeah
and i hadn't took none of my medication
or anything for a long time before but
when i first got receiving i had been
off my meds for a long time so my viral
account was really really high which is
what i thought was weird i know my um
like i said my viral current was high so
i'm pretty sure when i if i was the
person that infected him which i most
likely was that he should have been like
right then and there but it wasn't took
a long time because hiv takes a while to
get into his system anyways but
i wasn't with anybody for the whole year
so it had to be randy oh yeah and these
same chromosomes and stuff other things
everybody ever since we met we just
never we never parted after we met it
matched so
much we even take the same age i'll be
missing now mm-hmm
what are your biggest regrets
[ __ ] regrets not me and himself
actually no
stop it
i'll meet him soon or maybe my life
would have been differently maybe his
life would have turned out differently
too yeah
no love his love is
maybe he wouldn't be as i'd have been
positive
there's no explaining it
it is what it is see maybe if he would
have made me sooner before the bozos he
met before
he would probably be hiv positive and i
probably wouldn't be
anything happens to a reason now but
then again
in the gay community christmas no yeah
sleeping around is calling so i think my
only regrets like i try not to have too
many regrets i mean they can't live life
like that hold back a bunch of regrets
and stuff you'll never be happy
but the very
very few i do have i want to say one is
probably dropping out of school
honestly and my second one would
probably be my um whole my whole drug
addiction thing you know what i mean
that i kind of regret a little bit
because at times it can kind of take
over your life and kind of mess up
i wouldn't change nothing about my life
because it made me person who i am today
if i would i wouldn't hadn't gone
through anything in my life that i went
to i would never face it it's
interesting how many people i've talked
to that have
you know obstacles like you do stephen
who have told me that exact same thing
that they wouldn't they wouldn't trade a
thing um
less and well-launched you know
lessons alone it's almost like these
these setbacks make us stronger yes they
make us who we are defining because if i
would have went through it and had top
skin i probably would have committed
suicide well god knows what
yeah you wouldn't be able to prepare to
handle something like that with hiv and
all that and yeah
suicide so i thank god every day i went
through all the tests the trials
tribulations everything i went through
wouldn't change it for one minute and
you're living in a new place now then
yeah then the last time where you had to
climb the stairs mm-hmm oh there's only
like three steps and i said
oh it's temporary of course until we get
round feet and get somewhere else to
move but for now it's a lot better but
you're you're supporting yourselves how
now
um we are we have a friend that helps us
out until we get in our feet honestly
and you get on your feet how about you
getting um by getting um we're waiting
ready for his disability and just i've
done my housing
whatsoever it only helps us out with
food and place it live thank god
for that doing interviews on youtube
yeah
that's why that too helps
thank god every little bit
truly
interesting
and you have hope for a brighter future
yes most definitely you guys seem very
optimistic yeah it's got to be yeah
especially stephen who's been through so
much
and i still gotta
get the rest of my leg cut off so you
can get back to the hospital that's the
thing we're getting right put him back
in the hospital but we're gonna do this
today first and after we leave here
we're gonna have to put him back in the
hospital and he has to get more um
surgery done oh is that right so you're
going and when
hopefully we'll soon
you watch me go today but
they wanted me friday i went to urgent
care and they uh
um it's a mercy out patient thing they
wanted to call neighbors
jose on me but
my birthday and everything and just
coming up and kind of need the money and
everything again
it's not all about the money it's about
i want to make sure he's stable enough
but that's got to be it's got to be a
scary thing for you right oh yeah i've
got to make sure he's okay before i go
in it's not about money it's not about
anything i'll be okay i want to make
sure you guys are still you're worried
about him you're getting your leg cut
off and you're worried
typical
i'm starting to learn about your
relationship now yeah
i see how this actually yes
money's all important to me it's about
making sure he's stable
now that i go in the hospital and he
gets kicked out of a place that we're
staying right now which possibly could
have could happen
so i'm gonna make sure if i go in which
i'll be in here for a while because i'm
not my husband not my house not doing
good at all it's not doing good at all
so
we've got some really bad news and stuff
my hiv has moved down below to the age
level now it's not been
so that affects your health
no you feel less strong or less
weak just tired i went to sleep that's
all i'm going to sleep doing to sleep
and you're taking the medication oh yeah
we just started a new the same
medication i take he just not started
it might take a while to kick in perhaps
yeah because
it takes place it's actually really good
the one i take or we take now is really
really good it doesn't make me cute all
the time something doesn't make me puke
i think that's the only thing different
i've been inducing my wife is that
makes him get like he threw up this
morning before we got here but every day
that was kind of like oh my gosh i was a
little late today getting here because i
was getting sick yeah and and so we
talked a little bit about the racism in
this part of the country is is there
randy you kind of felt like there isn't
a whole lot of it and stephen is
convinced that there's
i mean i've dealt with it a little bit
but it's been more so in other states
really then i've dealt with it here
truly of course he hasn't been outside
his city new mexico yeah i've been
outside city limits he never been in the
deep
i was the only black person there and i
didn't feel any type of racism but i got
adopted when i was younger i was adopted
about people who had rebel flags you
know hanging up on a wall and everything
and so they didn't really seem racist
towards me and half my mom's family you
know how my family's white there's
racists here
there's more
they're probably more careful around him
displaying like the landlord we
where we lived that was racist
i just kept telling him we can't report
the randy when i was there's also people
that are that discriminate against gays
yes
yeah yeah yeah yep
most of them get used to salvation
against people with in wheelchairs and
oh yeah
against gay people you just gave herself
and if they
are mutually racist they're probably
jealous or they don't have a black man
like me so okay the worst thing i want
to say when it comes to racism here i
notice is like in certain stores you go
to certain stores and they will follow
you around
you first go in and they will be you
know watch you from before they first
come in and they'll send somebody around
behind you the whole thing is this
because you're black yes i swear i know
it sounds crazy but that means that if
it's around black persay
or what it is but i feel like a lot of
times they just kind of associate my
skin color with um like a minority or
like i don't have the money to be in
certain stores like stacy did that to
him like i'm gonna go in there well you
definitely stick out in this part of the
country oh yes there and i'm using you
in san francisco la new york you'd be
fine i would yeah but here that's what i
tried to tell him he was like oh you
always stand out people always looking
at us i'm like babies something you have
to get you assuming you wear something
just mad because i speak out like i said
you're going to say we got a
i think i could wear a trash bag over my
body and everything and i would still
get the same reaction people i really
believe that truly
i think it's kind of just like my eyes
those are the same colors of trash bags
yeah stop it
terrible
all right you guys well thank you so
much for coming in again i wish i wish
you lots of luck steven with your
surgery no yes i hope it goes well
definitely keep you updated
you see the infection it's coming out
much
mm-hmm oh is that is that an infection
there that's pulling it yeah it's not
good
she said we gotta go get that handle
today
they just never got done fixing out so
all right
good luck with that thank you thank you
we'll see you guys again hopefully thank
you
you